[Music]
yes yes it is us oh
The Leftovers
[Applause]
back from Thanksgiving enjoying our good
God blessed American holiday
and if there's one thing I learned it's
that the Native Americans had it coming
right Hassan of course yeah that's
that's the important lessons that you
learn from from Thanksgiving
you know what I learned from
Thanksgiving domestic terrorists you
know what I learned from Thanksgiving a
lesson I learned every [ __ ] year and
I just refuse to recognize said lesson
turkey's mid it's mid it's mid we taught
yeah turkey's mid everyone there's a
reason we only eat it once a year yeah
yeah it's mid like it's not that good
you it needs to get hard carried by
stuffing mashed potatoes gravy and even
then it's like you're still like oh man
dry I would like honey ham I feel like
would be way better they go they go oh
oh I gotta baste it like a hundred times
before it's done it's like yeah it's not
good yeah you have to put butter in
under its skin okay
I don't know I've Maybe
it wasn't good did you have turkey my
grandma made it it was all right it's
just like it's just mid it's not good
but we're Turkish so we have like uh I
love first of all I love Thanksgiving
um I love all of the American holidays
they're so much fun
um for the family if you would think
that Turkish people would cook the best
turkey ah ah here it is hey there it is
uh
I learned about like the the reason why
it's called turkey or Hindi in Turkey
which is India uh it's just where the
original like uh the original formation
of the bird which we Now understand the
turkey came from for it was like Turkish
merchants
selling them yeah it was like again I
think it's called guinea okay kind of uh
it's like some kind of bird it's like
easily domesticated
okay a little a little Thanksgiving
trivia for us yeah love that
yeah but uh so you know my turkey was
pretty good this year and I don't know
what happened but you know my mom made
it who's not even a good Chef
traditionally but I gotta say the turkey
kind of slapped
so just putting that out there okay why
are you gonna Flex on me like that I
don't know my mom usually she can't cook
but but the turkey was good and I I'm
not trying to say anything about your
grandma we we also eat like sure just
lovely yeah no she made like incredible
alanazik it's just like a it's like a
Turkish uh dish uh it's uh it's like
pureed creamy eggplant puree basically
underneath and then on top of you have
like ground beef kind of I don't know
how to describe it I'm not doing a good
job describing it but like it's that's
okay that's decadent you know they
she's very good at that sort of stuff we
eat like mostly Turkish food and
Thanksgiving it tastes like beef jerky
does it taste like beef jerky what is
that from oh that's that's yeah that's
Fouseytube oh he he keemstar gave him a
piece of beef jerky and he said it
tastes like beef jerky so oh yeah which
it was great Lord thank you
congratulations yeah and if you guys
have any good arguments over
Thanksgiving yes we did as a matter of
fact I had jenk over uh the young
turks's very own Jank who is my uncle I
am a nepotism hire he was he was
trending on Twitter for I guess the the
right quote-unquote was laughing at him
because he said what did he say he said
he said these guys on the right are
always projecting and they are literally
pedophiles but they love claiming the
left are pedophile groomers but they are
the gray no he was right about that
that's not what we argued on we actually
agreed on that and then we quickly
started arguing on uh his his advocacy
for Rick Caruso and now like he thinks
oh yeah I didn't know that he's like he
is unhinged bro wait he's a fan of Rick
he's not a fan of recaruso he thinks
free cruso sucks obviously but he hates
Karen bass okay and thinks that like the
Democratic party's incompetence like
Eric Garcetti and Karen bass like they
are the same and they're not going to do
anything at least recruso would have
shook things up and he also wants to
like legitimately punish people like he
thinks he is totally on board with like
the narrative that crime is exploded but
nobody's reporting it because cops are
not showing up to crime scenes so people
just don't even report it there's like
homeless people you know doing sexual
assaults in every corner that sort of
thing okay by the way I'm sorry I forgot
to mention this this episode which has
nothing to do with the homelessness
issue here in L.A is sponsored by
doordash yes that's great that's a great
segue on what you were saying about uh
sexual unrelated to doordash but uh no
he was just like he's been saying crazy
[ __ ] he was just like why do you think
toothpaste is locked up as CVS I'm like
oh yeah because people are poor like
yeah and he's like well they're stealing
it because they know they can steal it
I'm like no they're stealing it because
they're poor are you exposing him right
now no no no we we had this live on
camera oh you did yeah we had this and
plus he's like
he's advocated for these things on
camera on his own show okay he recently
got exposed
for taking you to Hooters I don't know
if you saw the people
I did well you and I talked about it if
you remember you wouldn't name him I
said it was chank and then the clip
showed up on the subreddit of him being
like I've taken my young nephews to
Hooters when they were kids and it
didn't turn them into conservatives yeah
no it was but I said well you took your
your nephews where
so 10 questionable character
I I look I mean I'd lived through it I
went there wasn't traumatizing at all it
was [ __ ] awesome like I get it yeah
don't do it okay don't do it well so you
are against it
um like there's maybe some numbers cut
off for the Hooters yeah obviously
but like the age cutoff is almost like
they wouldn't appreciate it anyway they
wouldn't even understand what the [ __ ]
going on if they're like that young you
know what I mean right but yeah it's
just weird you think it's weird maybe
it's not that bad it's just Hooters but
I think there's just something odd about
the restaurant that's called Hooters
restaurant a restaurant and they make
the how is that even legal by the way to
force your to force your waitresses to
wear tiny outfits I thought that would
be illegal I mean strip clubs also exist
Ethan you know but I mean like people
right people can do consensually uh that
kind of thing is also like super light
though it's not even like softcore or
anything it's just no they literally
wear like uh these these like crazy
bronze socks all the way up or what are
they called like the tight tights
exploding Milk porn I don't know I'll
show uh maybe you guys don't even know
here this is what they wear at Hooters
and they only
higher like young girls and they wear
this outfit it's really not about now
that you just have Instagram so they
don't even do this anymore like this was
like
like the back in the day this was your
your big you know maybe you hoped that
like a Hollywood producer came to your
our Kansas uh Hooters you know what I
mean now you can just go on Instagram
yeah I don't know post feet if it wasn't
called Hooters it wouldn't even be that
bad I feel like the name makes it like
so much more absurd yeah there it is
yeah no it is a it is a bygone era for
sure which is why I think a lot of
people like Nick Adams will like ride or
die for it and like I don't care about
it enough to defend it one way or the
other you know what I mean yeah it's
it's tame I don't think it shouldn't
exist I just think it's funny bring your
kids I am ride or die on the other hand
in the other direction for child beauty
pageants I am 100 anti-child beauty
pageants hamburgers there like I have
always been anti-child beauty pageants
the reason why I say this is because
every single one of these right wing
freaks hmm okay that like will do like
anti-pedophilia seminars an
anti-pedophilia [ __ ] like you know uh
these like rallies and stuff they always
love child beauty pageants no shot
anyone would admit to liking that there
is it's on video there's a I went to a
anti-cuties rally outside of Netflix and
I talked to these [ __ ] Q Anon guys
and the main organizer openly was like
well you know trout B patches are a
little different like my niece did that
and I was like bro what the [ __ ] do you
mean it's worse is yeah it's the worst
dog so I yeah always if you want to
catch a conservative on the [ __ ] back
foot always ask him like what do you
think about child beauty pageants yeah
okay there you go adult into Skies we
have a lot to talk about today so uh
leaving Thanksgiving behind let's just
get right into it
uh real quick teddyfresh.com new drops
out today that's all I'm gonna say I'm
Gonna Keep It Fast thank you
I want that the the polo tea which one
do you want Oh DMD bro you said I got
you oh yeah we ordered it we ordered it
right right Lena that [ __ ] was fire yeah
it's ordered the Poetry with like the
fluffy yeah that one's really nice I
want yeah where is it it's uh
since you asked me I'll open it yeah Oh
that's oh that looks so good oh my God
is this her is this unisex yeah yeah
okay good thank God so we got you a 3XL
okay great fuzzy neon color this sweater
or jacket I'm wearing today is here
uh this is the jacket I was wearing that
everyone loved that's that's far
tapestry jacket really is nice
um and then I was wearing also here's
the piece I'm wearing right now
bear brooch it actually has a
teddy bear brooch on it
Thank You Will Smith
and um
uh ELO's wearing this the other last
week which is like the bedazzled Jewel
gemstone hoodie and this one I was
wearing yesterday that everyone loved
this one's really nice it's a colored
dirt and shirt yeah that one's nice
super nice I love this one I like it so
there it is there's actually all kinds
of new stuff there thank you uh thank
you thank you yeah we'll have that for
you soon so we didn't have a 3XL no
and uh
in the building if you have any if you
have a XL or 2XL I'll rock it it might
be a little tight
it's all good Lena you we gotta XL let's
get this off the [ __ ] let's get this
King in there you've been working out
you feeling good finally extra large and
extra time I think no I'm just probably
like [ __ ] 17 18 is that most likely
is yeah I don't have a six-pack I have a
flabby gut maybe higher probably coming
out you've been working your ass off
yeah I have been uh I've gotten
incredibly strong so that's good like I
I've been uh able to do my recomp
um and I'm like reaching my old levels
of like
uh you know I'm reaching my old gym PR
levels which is great took a [ __ ]
year
um but as far as like cutting I'm just
gonna do it after like I'm gonna I'm
gonna get into a deeper cut afterwards
because I can't like
you know it's just been hard
you know speaking of uh exercise our boy
liver King I'm sure you heard oh I don't
he he like came to our [ __ ] studio
and lied to our faces
I ate I wouldn't didn't eat that but I
put raw bull testicles in my foot I ate
it man I [ __ ] ate it and you didn't
you didn't need to do that
the testes didn't make him look like
that Hassan it was the seven different
steroids twelve thousand dollars a month
milking hope
um so one a couple things I want to say
about this
one
you will not be able to achieve that
body
even if you just do his stack let's say
you have 15 grand lying around and you
[ __ ] shoot up and you you take the
oral supplements and everything that
liver King is taking yeah you're not
gonna look like that that requires a
tremendous amount of dedication I knew
that from the jump I knew that he was
most likely taking steroids but I also
still respected his regimen and most
people that go to the gym and people
that actually are honest about their
steroid usage will tell you that okay I
have a lot of friends who do
bodybuilding they have incredible Bodies
Okay incredible they're jacked they uh
they they focus on aesthetic they focus
on composition and that is impossible to
achieve unless you are literally doing
everything correctly like all the little
margins like you're having dextrose
right after a workout you know what I
mean like that's what liver King was
doing
um so
I think if he had even been honest about
his like steroid usage sure normies who
don't understand it would have probably
said oh you're cheating because a lot of
normies think that he is cheating though
yeah I mean there's a lot of people that
do the continuous part of it is yes uh
selling this yeah falsehood fraud and
claiming that like you two can become
like him as long as you take the liver
supplements that's funny bro but it's
it's doubly fraudulent because like it's
not just the [ __ ] liver supplements
that make him look like that it's not
just the steroids that make him look
like that it is the tremendous like
insane amount of working out that he
does he walks 13 miles on his off day
like those conversations between more uh
the the ones that were leaked to more
plates more dates yeah
it showed that he was working out twice
a week eating super close to what he's
actually claiming with like additional
supplements a week or it worked out
twice a day sorry yeah uh even on his
off day walking 13 miles yeah um
definitely clearly has like a tremendous
amount of body dysmorphia because he was
like hyper focusing on his back yeah
which is non-existent like you're crazy
um and uh yeah he is still like a very
impressive he could have been just like
an impressive funny guy you know what I
mean but I don't think anyone would have
really he I don't think he would have
been as big if he was like yeah I'm on
steroids I don't think he would have
caught on he looks like a freak he looks
crazy
but uh yeah I I don't think it would
have got him anywhere but I think you're
making a good point about the fact that
it's not even the steroids he's like
super wealthy for some reason and he has
got trainers and doctors and coaches and
is able to basically commit like the end
of his day no more importantly than all
of that dude more importantly all that
he's got [ __ ] he has got immense
willpower like this is his [ __ ] like
this is it's not easy to get up every
[ __ ] day
no matter what happens bro it's because
he reached out to you and called you a
primal app no no I know what this is no
I think he's he's a scammer he's a
scammer obviously
um but I'm just I'm just trying to be as
like well balanced on this issue as
possible because like no matter what
happens like it doesn't discount the
tremendous amount of work that goes into
uh you know making yourself look like
that and you might not appreciate it but
it's not for you it is hard work but
also so okay whatever who cares don't
call you a prime it's like he most
people don't want don't even have access
to the time and money to do that oh 100
you know hard work is cool but like I
feel like there's a lot of people who
are like
yeah I'd love to work out all day if I
had the time and money
yeah no he's he's got
um you know he's got some if you want to
get some issues if you want to get in
his head though talk about back fat
apparently what's up liver King that bat
dude if you want to get if you want to
get into that you should ask him how his
liver is doing man like bro you're not
good he wasn't even just taking the
ancestral supplements for his liver
which are like fine you know whatever
but he was also taking additional Liver
Health supplements on top of that
because if you stack [ __ ] like that
that's going to filter through your
liver liver your liver is busted dog not
going well liver King has the liver of a
seven the 75 year old man okay so uh
moving past that Russian are so sad so
sad liver king
um
this [ __ ] really came and yelled
sub Primal in my face when he had seven
different steroids going through his
body I mean come on
I'm more Primal you should do his stack
I don't [ __ ] care content idea you do
a stuff this is all natural we get you
[ __ ] yakt okay we get you [ __ ] act
you're still wearing the you're still
wearing a fat girl under my head looks
like a basketball bro the son really
wants to get you jacked I want to get
yeah
we were looking up all the medicine he
was on he was on like some weird
expensive experimental [ __ ] it wasn't
even approved for human consumption like
yeah a lot of the a lot of the a lot of
the steroids are from horses anyway like
most people that take stairs I mean a
lot of people think stairs are taking
like horse steroids like clenbuterol is
a horse uh horse asthma medication you
start doing this
but yeah I mean you've been looking even
good you've been looking healthy like
I've seen like it was respect to like
older videos even like the liver King
video
because you've been taking the selfies
all natural yeah so um
we by the way Kanye West is on Infowars
right now and we were I was going to
talk about Kanye West yeah about
today he was on Tim pool
yeah Nick Fuentes I saw you finally had
to talk about that Nazi [ __ ] yeah I've
Ethan knows like every time Nick Fuentes
like I don't know is outed as like
someone who has a boyfriend who's a cat
boy or someone who is like uh I think he
is he was also out of that too like is
it Chaser yeah every time when that
stuff used to happen anything would be
like yo let's cover it on leftovers I
was like no I don't want to talk about
this [ __ ] freak because I don't want
to give him even a little bit like he's
in the margins he doesn't have that big
of an audience I don't want to give him
any [ __ ] light whatsoever and now it
doesn't matter because Kanye was like no
that guy I'm gonna make him famous that
guy's dub yeah my guy he said that guy
who says uh having sex with black white
women having sex with black men are akin
to uh bestiality Nick Fuentes said that
yeah and he also said it's white
people's time right now uh to vote and
if we mess it up I don't believe in
democracy we need to get Trump in office
to make sure he never leaves he actually
hates black people which is what's so
interesting about their Alliance yeah I
mean but it doesn't matter like he he
doesn't care well so no he's the irony
the irony of course is
Nick Fuentes okay so like as a as a
white supremacist with the last name
like I don't think he recognizes or I
don't think he cares that eventually
like
that's just not gonna last that
Allegiance is not going to last for a
very long time you know what I mean not
to not to talk about what you said about
Ben Shapiro but that's kind of how it
works you know these guys they will turn
on you eventually they will say hey
you're not white either Nicholas Fuentes
funny that you mentioned Ben Shapiro
because I want to talk about how
he's basically afraid of the monster
he's built now that Kanye's out there
doing the anti-Semitism World Tour but
Kanye is on live with Alex Jones right
now and we're just pulling I think this
is by far his craziest interview he's
ever done
and we're pulling clips of it right now
that we're gonna watch Twisted Fantasy
yeah Jordan Peterson's a fan but before
that I don't know he said the Jews are
the Canary in the coal mine once people
start going after Jews world changing
events will happen wait do we have that
clip I saw that yeah I said I said
Jordan I'm not a canary but actually I
like what he said it's just it's not
dumb yeah I mean it's not false either
he's right like everything's not at all
I'm everybody Jordan yeah I'm a human
being no you're a canary Ethan even Jews
are canaries Ethan I saw a dream my
grandma and her pubic hair and you were
there as well
my friend Ethan Clapping Your clown
flapping your Canary Wings he flew past
my grandmother's pubes married he
dropped from the sky exposed dimly oh
the appearance of a thick mat of air he
tried to tell me stop
the canary started picking lice out of
my grandmother's Pew oh God oh God you
were doing that you're the canary he was
Ethan Klein he was a Jew all right here
here's a new Jordan Peterson these guys
have like literally aligned so
frequently with [ __ ] straight up
neo-nazis that it's kind of funny where
they're like hold on now Nazism there's
no place for that in our Nazi movement I
mean yeah Jordan has always been a
as far as I'm aware he's always kind of
people have been
poking him for the Jew stuff I remember
a few years ago before he went totally
radical people were like what are your
thoughts on the Jewish question yeah I
wonder why people ask him that by the
way so how strange that your audience is
regularly trying to hear your
perspective on whether we should
exterminate the Jews or not yeah but his
his answer was great he was said
basically said no I don't think we
should kill all the Jews so I was like
well that's a relief
for daily wire even though their boss is
uh Ben Shapiro but here's bet here's a
Jordan once again talking about trans
people here it is I saw a surgeon on
some chat yesterday the day before who
was bragging about doing 3 000 double
mastectons for me that's like that's
Auschwitz
imagine all the budding breasts I could
have caressed that's awesome it's
basically Australia bro that's crazy
Auschwitz famous for consensual
surgeries they're both parties consented
to but those numbers are insanely exact
there's no way he must be talking about
cancer patients because I don't even
think there's been that many yeah no
gender affirming double mastectomies
yeah
if you have tit cancer you better not
get a mastectomy I will find you
let that cancer titties will stay on
that body yeah they're beautiful and
you'll die beautiful yeah do you have
back pain it's an affront to God if you
get a breast reduction let me suck on
those titties at least once before you
cut them off sorry not beautiful it's
outfits unless they're fat then you can
cut them off
day before I love that bro who was
bragging about doing 3 000 double
mastectomies for me that's like that he
wasn't brag you know what I mean like
nobody's bragging about that it doesn't
make I saw it so that's Auschwitz yeah
he said Jews are canaries in the social
coal mine when anti-Semitism becomes a
moral necessity even in its subtler
forms hell is about to make its
appearance yet again
I appreciate frankly any of the
conservatives that are tweeting and
saying [ __ ] like that so in a way I I
was like you know that's good because
right now there's a lot of people scared
on the right to say anything like that
because it's his anti-Semitism has
become so uh dude that's literally not
even genuine though they're doing it to
cover their asses they're doing it I
know but like the problem is they're
they built this bed right the ones that
are covering their asses aren't saying
anything
no the ones that no the like Jordan
Peterson has said that about like the
Jewish question right because like when
faced with that you have to literally
just you have two options either come
out as a Nazi and and not be able to
continue your grift in the same exact
way or openly State no that's
unacceptable now you might genuinely
believe that that's unacceptable but a
lot of these people don't the reason why
I think that a lot of these people do
not have a a genuine interest in like
defending uh Jewish people or attacking
anti-Semitism is because they routinely
partner with anti-semitic people
um that's the issue like you you allude
to anti-semitic conspiracies you
regularly partner with anti-semites and
neo-nazis you give a nod to them
regularly within your uh within your
commentary and Ben Shapiro is no
different like well that was the whole
point of my joke that got me a
suspension yeah that's what I mean you
were like you were right on the money
observation you know yeah you were right
on the money with that like a lot of
these people laid in bed with these anti
semites and now that like some of them
are coming out and being like Oh I'm
like straight up a Nazi then now they're
like don't say that yeah surprise
Pikachu face because you're giving the
game away if your politics are so
closely associated with like Neo-Nazi
politics which it is
um then the moment that you just openly
stated you're giving the game away to a
lot of people because even racist people
don't want to be called Races they know
that that's a bad thing the
conservatives are so one at all costs
you know that they're they're willing to
Ally with these people and then they
realize like oh [ __ ] they actually want
me to die ultimately but let me open
Infowars and just see what they're
talking about this is let's take a look
this is live right now she's kind of was
taking over the thing so at the end of
the day we worship a Jew or we say he's
not really a Jew we worship it's not the
same thing though because the kind of
Judaism that we have now is not of the
Old Testament it's of the rabbinical
oral tradition so these people are
worshiping there's no such thing as
Orthodox Jews anymore all movement comes
from
blaming Jews for this I'm blaming the
leftist ADL to deny why does this
[ __ ] prank shut off Wikipedia
like this like I don't understand he's
got this big beautiful Technic Technic
[ __ ] technological set and then he's
got I mean Rob our studio design a
little bit which is kind of [ __ ] up
like yeah I think we have an IP Alex
Jones stole the studio from a Jew right
here ladies and gentlemen Ethan Klein he
had the real Studio first but we were in
the bunker first Alex Jones stole it
from us but seriously this is insane
what is this he's printing up sheets of
paper yeah I don't know what the [ __ ]
going on here
pause for a second dude they're so nerdy
like the [ __ ] that they are talking
about with respect to like Judaism or
whatever the [ __ ] it's like dude why
what are you saying I mean it's all
insane it's all insanity but also like
just watch anime or something okay learn
about like they do the anti-lore even
that would be infinitely more normal
than whatever the [ __ ] you're doing
you're like you're like learning about
you know instead of learning about like
Dungeons and Dragons characters or
whatever the [ __ ] right and and how to
roll adequately you learned about this
[ __ ] and it broke your [ __ ] brain you
like read into this like false lore
pecker is mad
I thought that was my videos like what
the [ __ ] oh no get the elite shoes to
control the 99 which are the masses
those elements are water food shelter
medicine education what are those five
elements are the most important
education because with the knowledge you
can go get water you can go get food you
can get shelter and you could get
medication yeah that's why donda Academy
was popping I agree and
and then also you know for me well Kyrie
I love Kyrie he he did what his job was
they had the Hebrew Israelites in front
of the game and now the high schools I
always think about the high schools I
always think about the future the
grammar schools yeah whatever so I'm
gonna go back and and show they've been
going on for a minute but here let me
show you because you haven't seen any of
this so we pulled some of the best ones
God oh no that wasn't yeah he brought
out his his comedy routine uh his best
prop show he comes on opens up
he takes a deep jab at Netanyahu which
of course I mean who likes Netanyahu
anyway but yeah he does suck but uh he
comes out really hard hard line check
this out and there is certainly uh
leftist Jews that call everybody Nazis
they don't agree with you you don't open
borders you don't want your guns taken
or you don't want to take a shot the ADL
had a meeting last two weeks ago and
said Alex Jones is an agent of evil he
should be taken off the air he's the
devil because he doesn't want you to
take four shots and I'm like what are
you doing calling me anti-semitic I'm
not against groups I don't get into
group politics Adam I've got I mean
sorry sorry I didn't mean to say that uh
uh Alex yes sir Adam I've got Adam Jones
perfect answer for the ADL
they are gonna have to listen up what we
did is we brought Netanyahu with us
here we go
a Yahoo drink
what do you have to say what do you have
to say to Alex Jones right now Nick
Fuentes
bro this is the most he is so whack dude
wait that's the most divorced that ass
joke you could have ever captured dude
what the [ __ ] I was I'm thinking we need
to put Kanye in a conservatorship like
free Brittany La Kanye or you have so
many funny things you can say about
Netanyahu like he's literally from
Philadelphia if you want to just make
fun of that if you want to be
anti-semitic that's a great place to
start
you could just say he's from
Philadelphia be like Israel take a major
L that like they they keep they keep
electing this guy who's who's a crook
but he's also from Philadelphia imagine
letting someone from Philadelphia run
your country no shot that's like the Dr
Oz uh exactly well John fetterman's cool
but he's at least he's from Pittsburgh
I'm just be honest if you're gonna hate
a Jew let's do Netanyahu don't bring out
the net and the Yahoo come on get in
there boy
I yeah that's so whack oh God what is he
doing it's bad it was let's get worse
hey
he loves it yeah you're so funny
so you don't like Benjamin Young
I just I just heard about this guy two
weeks ago
Dude oh he had a funny name I'm sorry
he's just learning about like he's he's
in his baby anti-semite era like that's
what I'm saying like he's gonna start
he's ready to be president he just
learned about Benjamin Netanyahu two
weeks ago oh God he just has a funny
name is there more to know about him I
just know he's a Jewish man with a funny
name heard he's like really into like
he's like a super killer and I could die
for saying this so
I'm glad you guys are here and we can we
can we can sit here and upset all I'm
telling you is
do you guys realize that
created Hitler and the milder group he's
like let's get back into the let's get
back into the room you said the British
government
personally let's get right back into the
real stuff those shoes are great people
and I and I understand there's a Jewish
Mafia and they're they're wait who's the
girl who's a great people he said we go
back what is he saying he's like dude
power and there's something much more
sophisticated and I personally uh think
that most shoes are great people and I
you know
he said I think I personally think most
Jews are great people oh yeah no Alex
has been defending the Jews yeah he's a
he um he's a good man that Alex Jones
that's interesting I wonder he's got
he's got to have a big Evangelical base
of support in Texas that is like super
pro-israel so that's probably part of
the reason why he's like staying away
from that because he knows how to read
the room you know he's just
I I don't think he's gonna damn even
Alex Jones is not [ __ ] no he's he
dude Alex Jones this whole time is
distancing himself yeah he's like a lot
all right Kanye I don't know about this
Jew stuff everybody you gotta calm down
here let's pull up the next clip he
actually is he like div because there
was another clip where he was like
debating Nick Fuentes on like how
responsible for everything uh you know
what I just have that one in there well
I'm pulling him up we got a bunch of
them here is Alex Jones
this one I mean they're all crazy to be
called that a demonized well
I I see I I see good things about Hitler
also the Jew I love everyone and Jewish
people are not going to tell me you can
accept Jewish people
yeah he says I love everybody wait why
are they what are these what is this
year old dog what is this b-roll the
American History X but why did they put
that as a b-roll what is happening [ __ ]
is this in here why the [ __ ] are you
doing that
dude I don't know what the [ __ ] going
on but I love that Connie always says
like I love everybody I have love for
everyone including Hitler but like he
but not the Jews
it seems weird man it seems like you
don't have love for everybody then why
did they do that well I'm gonna take
that off you're not a Nazi you're not
enough to be called that and demonized
we're not showing it Ian took it off
okay okay I like so Alex is trying to
queue him up he's like you're not a Nazi
this is ridiculous and he goes well
actually well
I I see I I see good things about Hitler
also the Jew I love everyone and Jewish
people are not going to tell you don't
show this you can why are they love [ __ ]
um you know us and you can love what
we're doing to you with the contracts
and you can love what we're you know
what we're pushing with the pornography
but this guy that
invented highways invented the very
microphone that I use as a musician you
can't say out loud that this person ever
did anything good wait and I'm done with
that stop does he think Adolf Hitler
invented highways and the microphone
he's using he just said that he
literally said that bro that's crazy
what
oh no what the [ __ ]
the the inventions of Hitler well the
Nazis did trailblaze the uh
National highways yes the Autobahn uh
but like first of all that predates uh
uh Hitler's rule that's number one two
there were logistical reasons for it but
like it's not like they inve like Adolf
Hitler I mean they they installed a
massive Road system so that they could
mobilize for war yeah yeah but I'm
saying like Adolf Hitler didn't invent
that no he was there digging the
trenches no he yeah he's like Elon Musk
you know and he was in the labs
yeah there's a little bit more here that
I use as a musician you can't say out
loud that this person ever did anything
good and I'm done with that I'm done
with the classifications every human
being has something of value that they
brought to the table especially Hitler
you're not
it goes you're not a Nazi and it's kind
of being like no I am actually yeah
because they invented the microphone
what's interesting he says you're not a
Nazi he doesn't go no I'm not a Nazi but
he goes he doesn't even say that he goes
well actually
yeah pretty crazy
so there is Kanye uh giving praise to
Hitler which is interesting because
there's been reports
that he's been praising Hitler privately
yeah for years yeah the Adolf yeah
and a lot of people are like no way
right like there's no way and uh well
there it is it's just out in the open
now uh Kanye West Praises Hitler more
and attacks the Jewish people you you
have to recognize one thing here which
is that every conservative that was like
super on board with Kanye literally like
lasts a week because he was repeating
Candace owens's [ __ ] bars you know
verbatim they gonna get wet they loved
it they loved it and now they're like
wait a minute Kanye's being exploited by
Nazis and I'm like yeah he was already
like he was on your show Stephen Crowder
he was already you know when you were
praising him for saying that like George
Floyd uh was was not a real victim or
like he was chosen to be [ __ ]
executed to start the false BLM riots or
whatever the [ __ ] when you loved it he
was doing the exact same [ __ ] back then
you just you know loved it because he
wasn't overtly anti-Semitic I like how
none of them are willing to accept that
this is the ultimate Road in which their
political ideology their their
Ultra conservatism goes down you know
what I mean this is this is where at
least this is The Logical conclusion if
you [ __ ] are constantly looking for
uh different Avenues I mean this is
eventually where you're going to go to
that's why anti-Semitism is at the heart
of a lot of these conspiracy theories
because ultimately you have to have if
you don't have a a materialistic uh
understanding if you don't have a
materialist analysis of history and
contemporary Society then you have to
find like some idealistic interpretation
right some people go to spiritual ones
where it's like oh God or Karma or some
other reason for why evil things are
happening or you have to find a group of
villains okay I personally believe if
you want to take like a good and bad
approach which I don't believe I don't I
I don't try to apply moralism uh
moralistic attitudes to why people
behave a certain way I think
self-preservation preservation is the
main reason but if you if you don't
recognize that it's Capital owners then
you have to find like a seedy dark Shady
group of people and who are you going to
always Point finger of blame at Jewish
people that's who they've always
historically pointed the blame at you
know what I mean to me
the pogrom's bloodline
yeah point to me but you want me to
point to you uh we got him got him Hey
There He Is We got him so
but that that is The Logical conclusion
if you think that people are evil and
you think some people are good and you
know there's like someone pulling the
puppet strings which there are people
pulling the public strings they're just
Capital owners across the board it's not
Jewish people it's Capital owners people
who own a lot of capital well the one
thing that Alex Jones and a lot of other
conservatives who get the chance to talk
to Kanye
Tim pool all the way down they go yeah
there are bad Jewish people but not all
Jewish people right like like you're
generalizing too much and Kanye will not
he will not concede that yeah he really
thinks all Jewish people yeah Kanye If
he if he had just you know if he found
Lenin instead of uh you know Candice
Owens he would have been he would have
been down a very different trajectory I
think right now like I'm I'm reminded of
Lennon's famous speech about like
it's it's about Capital uh and capital
owners there are you know millions of
exploited Jews who are Jews in the
working class they are being exploited
by Capital owners as well just like
everyone else
so here is Kanye once again praising
Hitler and now people are like wait a
second the
wait
what is happening here deserve deserve
punishment what did I I thought that's
right you're not Hitler you're not what
the [ __ ] it was showing him talking
about Kanye
more
what do you mean like wait a second the
so-called crime doesn't deserve the
punishment what did I I thought that's
right you're not Hitler you're not a
Nazi you don't deserve to be called that
a demonized well this is the clip we
just watched guys yeah this is the same
one
let me see sorry we're all adding at the
same time maybe there was someone
overlapped this is two and we already
watched it anyway that was the one that
we just watched the same clip as the
other ones I yeah oh yeah this is this
the right but right before yeah he just
straight up said he likes Hitler Nazis
the mafias are doing either Hitler
what a [ __ ] weirdo you got that sound
bite Zach Hitler yeah he loved Hitler
they gave him an award I'm just saying I
don't like Nazis I I don't like what
some of the mafias are doing either
Hitler
what a [ __ ] psycho by the way Alex
Jones is such a unit man he is like
busting out of that denim jacket
yeah I usually Kanye likes to like drip
out everyone in his periphery you know
what I mean that's why he's like got
Nick Fuentes wearing that ugly ass
[ __ ] Gap uh you know that that Gap
hoodie everywhere he goes uh this is
that she's probably stinky as Hell by
the way God damn and by the way that
boy's been wearing that same [ __ ]
hoodie for like three weeks now bro
every time I see him every time I see
him on camera like at the you know at
the [ __ ] Hibachi place
in in like uh you know some some random
[ __ ] Pennsylvania suburb uh he's he's
wearing that blue thing
um
he didn't get Alex to wear it though it
seems nah Alex is blazed out in his yeah
Alex was like no I got my own trip Kanye
you will never make me wear that
Balenciaga they got pedophiles
um so sorry to interrupt but we gotta do
an ad
all right one more this one is 50 only
15 seconds okay I've said it the most
nazi-like activities I've seen
um and the Nazis it might be worse hugs
it shook people down to a lot of really
bad things but they did good things too
we're gonna stop dissing the Nazis all
the time Alex
my freak brain is just like
I I can't I just I it sucks I've been
saying this for a while it's like
basically coming uh everything I've
called out is like happening in real
time you know what I mean I'm sorry it's
just like it's a it's a bit of a
gloating moment for me you gotta stop
dissing the Nazis all the time
this is the same clip again guys
uh my accounts because they've been
frozen by the Jewish uh Banks so I I
need to watch my meals well CNN says why
people are evil Nazi so I mean I I
disagree with both statements but I get
the truth I don't like the word evil
next to Nazis I think we need to look at
oh my goodness just because you don't
like one group doesn't mean yet but I
look like I love Jewish people but I
also love Nazis right
oh man well I have to disagree with that
but listen Alex is out here [ __ ]
playing the straight man I've never seen
this before you know
but he's having fun and I like that for
him he's having a good time and one more
here Kanye says Nick Fuentes is the
future president let's all pray
the future president you're talking to
right now
is Nick your running mate
he's not old enough that's what they
want this is the future president you're
talking about even even Nick Fuentes
like who who is famous for eating his
own boogers who's like some of the one
of the grossest people Virgin by the way
yeah like never touched a woman uh even
he's like like Kanye you're you're
making us look bad right now a little
bit
all right let's do our ad and then we'll
get in deeper but we're monitoring the
situation is that right God damn brother
that's some crazy ass [ __ ] right there
thank you thank you to
uh to doordash
um
you got back-to-back meetings errands to
run or chores to take care of what's the
secret to clearing your to-do list a
Little Help from door Dash
you can get dinner household essentials
or everything on your grocery list D
liver
along with restaurants you love you can
now get groceries and other essential
items delivered with doordash could
drink snacks and other household items
in under an hour
or the driver gets fired no I'm just
kidding
made that up
I was gonna say they're put to death or
something but no that wouldn't even be
okay nope nope he did not say that stop
it obviously not true that'd be illegal
they wouldn't okay let's move on all
right door dead well they said in an
hour they don't say or what though they
says get drinks snacks other household
items in under an hour or what
right every time you place an order for
pickup or delivery you're setting off a
chain reaction that helps give back to
the people who make your neighborhood
unique with over 300 000 Partners Ethan
you can support your neighborhood
go-to's or true and lowering and
lowering every late delivery there is
choose from your favorite National
restaurants like Popeyes Chipotle and
Cheesecake Factory which Kanye West
likes to go to but that's unrelated [ __ ]
now I'm doing it God damn it wait who
likes to go to Cheesecake Kanye West
does but it's fine it's unrelated to the
conversation
we should get back to the point here
okay he loves going like the national
you know food chains now because I don't
know he's poor he's he can't afford
um
you you with doordash you're not just
getting the things you love but
supporting the community that loves you
too from the stores and restaurants to
the Dashers driving around each person
just provides a new opportunity for
everyone involved because doordash
there's a neighbor of good in every
order now that's similar to what
no no no
no ah okay uh from yeah no um there's
good in everyone yeah for a limited time
our listeners can get 50 off up to a 20
value and zero dollars in delivery fees
when you download the doordash app and
enter the code leftovers it's actually
insane that's free money that's free
food yeah that's fifty percent up off up
to a 20 value and zero dollar delivery
fees when you download the doordash app
in the app store and enter code
leftovers don't forget that's code
leftovers for 50 off up to a 20 value
and zero dollar delivery fees with
doordash something subject to change
terms apply and on the real I use
doordash pretty much every day I love it
it's so convenient and I get all my
favorite foods there but this sweat
offers insane that's just free money
y'all so thank you to doordash and
please support our sponsor we love them
so much thank you thank you doordash
all right
yep there goes our final sponsor
he's not here but he's here in spirit
Dan is smoking somewhere right now he's
got smoke coming out of his ears
anyway back to the Nazis
um okay yeah
Nick Fuentes and so before they were on
uh uh Infowars today
uh
yay has been touring Nick Fuentes around
for
basically all week I wish I had a
compilation of all the crazy yeah let's
look at who Nick Fuentes is because
when you we sometimes we speak
hyperbolic about people and we say you
know other Nazis they're this they're
that Nick Fuentes is actually all those
things yes yeah no he is like he he
tries to distance himself from like uh
Richard Spencer who we know is like an
out and about Nazi right but they've had
multiple conversations where they've
like discussed tactics on how to like
continue promoting a white nationalist
narrative a white nationalist message
without just saying that they're a Nazi
like that was the big distinguishing
factor for this nerd uh over all the
other nerds uh in the white nationalist
Nazi movement was that like
they were basically trying to be like oh
we shouldn't be associated with like
being a Neo-Nazi because everybody once
they recognize your Neo-Nazi is like
you're over your career is done you're
not going to be able to promote this to
a broad audience you know give the game
away hide your power level that sort of
thing I don't think I didn't think he
was hiding anything I mean here check
this well he can't that's his main
problem is that like he never says he's
a Nazi openly right
um I don't think he's like ever sieg
heiled even I don't think he cares about
the label he just you know no no but he
but the but being planted with the label
Nazi limits your reach so he has tried
to do that but very unsuccessful because
he gets so [ __ ] horny to be
anti-semitic on you know on Main that he
just can't stop himself and then
everyone that's normal that sees a clip
like this goes oh [ __ ] that okay you're
done you're you're Nazi I'm done with
you
well I think it's worth showing a little
bit of who he is because this is the kid
who's now been uh launched to national
uh stage with Kanye he was on Temple he
met with Trump so let's just give you a
glimpse at who this [ __ ] is we
have got to talk about the fundamentals
of our world view
and what it would look like to build a
society based on our distinct world view
which is different from the left
different from a Godless atheist
constructivist liberal worldview
and what does that look like does that
look like a society we have gay marriage
and birth control and contraceptives no
legal ubiquitous internet pornography
I know you [ __ ] jerk off to porn
every night and yeah I think they have
like stop scored logs or something where
they'd like do gay [ __ ] Hypno to one
another and then they're like oh you
hypnotized me into being a catboy like
oh no which is pretty funny adult insist
yeah
but uh transgender kids aren't playing
in girls water polo no that's not what
it looks like it looks like a society
where women don't have the right to vote
Yes and it looks like a society where
boys and girls get married as teenagers
yes and start having kids and they don't
use birth control and they don't use
contraceptives and they have big
families
it's so sad
that part is just sad because he's just
like please why not exactly he obviously
just wants forced marriage so the guy
can have sex yeah he's like why not me
though for real like I wish I could have
had that dude what the [ __ ] it's like
life could have been so different if he
wasn't like the most relentless
annoying [ __ ] white supremacist nerd
and so yeah uh yeah I had the same
reaction I was like bro you're just say
you want a date you don't have to make
come on come on I'm a teenage oh God
there's a teenager I wish I could have
had a girlfriend and I got married young
teenagers need to be having kids 13. I
don't care we need more wines yeah it's
like it's it's crazy where he's like you
know uh trans people can't play water
polo but like if you're a teenager you
should literally get married okay
immediately to me
why not me yeah so this guy makes Ben
Shapiro look like Martin Luther King
or lack of a better oh no lack of a
better analogy
don't lose contraceptives and they have
big families and a high birth rate and
it looks like women wearing fails yes
he's been but like Ben did his dream
like he's describing the only thing
that's like bad about Ben and Nick finds
his eyes that he's Jewish but like Ben
is literally living make point this is
[ __ ] dream dude I just realized yeah
you know yeah and he makes a lot more
money than he does he's like making 43
million dollars a year and [ __ ] yeah
dude hold this L Nick God damn but he's
an ugly [ __ ] dude like no wonder
you want to force woman to marry your
ass because you were just not like vile
hot you know no but I'll tell you Ben is
starving he has charm he's better
looking than Nick that's for sure he's
put together this dude hasn't washed his
face in a century yeah you know the
funniest part is when you realize that
this is being shot in his mother's
basement
did you know that no yeah uh so Louis
Thoreau did a documentary on the on the
alt-right uh movement in America that
was released in the BBC for like last
year or maybe like in February this year
and I refused to watch it on stream for
the obvious reasons why I didn't want to
talk about Nick Fuentes for the longest
time and uh he just goes to his house
and and basically yeah he just streams
from his mommy and daddy's basement that
could be you know that could be one of
the reasons why you can't find someone
to marry you too and generally yeah
that's not that appealing Nick
no wonder this all explains I wonder
what a while to think that like Paul
gozar and Marjorie Taylor green have
like you know collaborated and went to
his like he goes home and sleeps in the
basement yeah his parents house yeah I
loved that he's so sweaty and greasy and
ugh so here we go yeah so again he says
women need to be wearing veils we love
that and it looks like women not being
in the workforce yes and it looks like
mothers raising their kids and it looks
like uh can you keep it down honey we're
trying to watch our soaps
his parents probably like it though they
they have to be yeah they can't be
[ __ ] oblivious or they're just yacked
out on like uh Xanax yeah they're like
honey can you keep down the video games
please
the pornography being banned yes and
homosexuality and transsexuality as well
as heterosexual sodomy as well as why do
you care home heterosexuals have thought
of me bro why are you a fun police ma'am
you're not allowed to have any sex
whatsoever until I have some I'm sick
and tired of people having sex all the
time we will be installing a camera and
every [ __ ] in America and if any
penis enters their phallic object you
will be charged
vacation and adultery being shamed by
the society and maybe in some places in
some jurisdictions regulated by the law
it's not enough to say we're against
[ __ ] you got to be against women's
rights too
it's not enough to be against
blue-haired feminism you got to be
against women getting educated
okay
right or else what are we really trying
to achieve here yeah 1999
1999 sucked two we won 1984. we want to
go back to to 10.99 we want to go back
to the Middle Ages yes
so we're burning your gay pride flag
we're burning your gay pride flow and
then we're gonna drag your [ __ ] wife
out of her house kicking and screaming
and then we're gonna burn her at the
stake too for being a witch
whoa again Trump
Kanye Tim Poole all hosted this guy yeah
uh that's just that's just wild that
like a lot of this [ __ ] gets away though
like that was one of the main things
that I was so pissed off about with like
Tim Poole having Kanye and Nick Fuentes
on like having Kanye on yeah Kanye's
like uh [ __ ] oblivious you know what
I mean it's a very obviously he didn't
even know who [ __ ] Netanyahu was
until like last week he's no apple T
he's a sideshow you know yeah yeah but
like this guy when you have him on like
you have to address him man you I like I
am in favor of never having Nick Puentes
on in any platform whatsoever yeah but
if you're gonna [ __ ] be stupid enough
to have him on you have to have the
decency to be like so you said here are
some things that you have said address
them now and you have to be very well
equipped to immediately counter those
talking points this shit's not easy you
need to load you need to learn the Deep
racism lore first okay A lot of people
are not well equipped to deal with
someone like this you can't if Tim pool
brings a guy like this on and even if he
like disagrees with him whatever
you are [ __ ] making him palatable
you're introducing your adjacent
audience to him and if you don't
Challenge and expose him yeah you're
just building this guy's profile so
congratulations Temple you [ __ ] I mean I
know you were dumb but uh yeah it's just
it's so I guess so [ __ ] up so here
let's just keep enjoying some Nick
Fuentes content here to let you all know
who Trump and yab and Tim Poole have
been spending their time with when it
comes to the Jews here's the silver
lining it tends to go from 0 to 60. like
they're not wrong about that but there's
a reason for that and the reason is them
okay when it comes to the Jews every
society where [ __ ] has gone down with
these people it always goes from zero to
sixty and never starts with burning all
the talmuds in Paris okay it never
starts that way
but frequently it seems to end that way
and it gets there very rapidly doesn't
start there but it frequently ends there
but I would say that the Jews had better
start being nice to people like us
because what what comes out of this is
gonna be a lot uglier and a lot worse
for them than anything that's being said
on this show or has been set on this
show in spite of the fact that I have
been bullied by the Jews and I have been
oppressed and slandered and lied about
and attacked by the Jews I have been
completely precise for the most part and
even-handed and nuanced about my view
about the situation what and I'm also a
Christian
which is gonna matter
because
there it could be a lot worse I'm gonna
say it in this show bro he's like
fantasizing about like a dystopia word
like I said it could be a lot uglier
than what we say on the show I know that
there are other people that are going to
push farther than that once this
conversation really not me though but
other people in my audience first and
say damn
I miss when it was just that funny guy
and we pushed so hard and then this and
that because
because history has shown that once this
train gets going
that's [ __ ] so this is the guy by the
way who Kanye saw fit to travel it's too
toxic this like no this backfires yeah
like every conservative [ __ ] knows
like again this guy
he he's done like you associate with
this guy it's gonna hurt your brand
you're not winning a national campaign
by even like aligning anywhere near what
uh Nick Fuentes says you can't even have
enough like um you can't even have
enough national news coverage to be like
oh they're actually unjustifiably uh
saying that Nick Fuentes is a Nazi when
he himself is like very regularly shown
that he is right so I think ultimately
he gives the game away it's like it's
like linking up with a [ __ ] Clan
member you know what I mean linking up
with a grand wizard you know his hope
and Kanye is definitely doing everything
in its power to achieve this is to make
you know anti-Semitism mainstream again
I'm gonna stop dissing the Nazis all the
time yeah and I I feel like they
actually have spoken about how do we
make Nazism and anti-Semitism mainstream
again I think that they have an end goal
of you know
of uh there's there's a reason rounding
up the Jews there's a reason why like
even Alex Jones and like most mainstream
Republicans will be like Democrats are
the Nazis because like everybody
understands they were bad okay we fought
them we won they were bad yeah same [ __ ]
with like slavery people who defend the
Confederate statues will still be like
well you know the clan like that's bad
but like we're just trying to protect
our heritage it's not hate like nobody
wants to be associated with like the
actual logical conclusions of these but
it can happen with this kind of rhetoric
happen it can I wouldn't say it no I
mean yeah nobody wants to now but it can
happen where they make it palatable I
just um to enough people
I know already that like Kanye's on like
every like so many shows are hosting him
at what point are people like
We're not gonna have you on anymore
because you're literally advocating for
like genocide
um I think that uh these are all like
banned shows you know what I mean like
these are all shows that have like
cultivated their own little uh Circle
well not Tim pool but he was on Joe
Rogan he was on right before he went
well Nazi I think he might go back on
Joe Rogan again yeah probably but the
thing is on a bunch of network
television like Steven Crowder
who defended Kanye West like last week
was criticizing him uh recently like his
last coverage of Kanye West was like oh
we were with you when you were getting
banned for no reason we wanted to defend
you but like now you're just saying like
like he'll he literally did the whole
like I get it there's a lot of Jews in
positions of power
but you're saying that they're in a dark
you know shadowy cabal which is
anti-Semitic and not acceptable like you
you see people pushing back on it you
see Mitch McConnell being like
anti-Semitism and white supremacy have
no [ __ ] place in our movement ironic
uh Mitch McConnell was posed in front of
a [ __ ] Confederate flag but
um but ultimately like
most Americans like I said have an
aversion to this level of like openly
stating that you're a [ __ ] uh Nazi or
uh a bad guy or now dude yeah it can't
wait yo Temple sisters and chat is that
right it can grow but at the moment as
it stands it's not profitable
it's still a toxic thing and they're
pushing it that's what I'm saying though
I'm afraid of what they're doing and I
feel like they have are making a
concerted effort to push through that
it's like a veil right that you do not
cross it's the ultimate taboo to be
racist or Nazi in American Society for
good reason obviously yeah and and their
push Kanye is like throwing his whole
[ __ ] life away to push through that
Veil and it's so [ __ ] dark and
dangerous and he is just Kanye has like
he's just what he's trying to do is
honestly couldn't be more [ __ ] evil
it's just so vile where's Tim Paul's
sister
do you guys see her in chat or what I'm
looking right now
uh the 10 Dono was Lisa pool I've been
trying to contact Tim's sister I want to
get her oh yeah Lisa pool can we I wish
my brother would stop having garbage
guests on his show Lisa pool that simple
sister yeah I heard she made a video
about Tim I haven't actually seen it
I've been trying to get her to call in
Lisa she's a member hahaha
yo Lisa reach out to one of the um mods
on Discord
are Olivia you're on Discord
a message Olivia uh Lisa and I'd love to
for you to call in I've been trying to
reach out to you I want to hear
about what a little [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ] your brother was
no I'm just kidding but maybe
oh I'm definitely posing this Temple uh
post that Ian just blasted
wait what's out look at the Discord
I'm posting the [ __ ] out of that dude on
Twitter in the wrong [ __ ] Discord God
damn it yeah
I'm posting it so because you can't
I can't post [ __ ] no yeah God damn it I
was in the wrong [ __ ] Discord
missed all these
um
this one okay here here we go I love
that let's check this out
I think you could actually win the
presidency well you are such a [ __ ]
loser he's such a [ __ ] dude he is so
[ __ ] made maybe maybe a 50 state
Landslide yeah for yay two hours later
well the funniest thing was when he was
like um I think you're running for
president will be really good for the
black vote like that's what he said the
Kaya was like you you have you've lost
every [ __ ] ounce of credibility that
you may have even had even if you had
any after the 58 Landslide thing when
you say to something like that like the
the assumption that like because Kanye
West is black and because he's a famous
black person that black people will like
Flock to him and vote for him is such an
obvious demonstration that like one you
have no [ __ ] idea how this works at
all and two it is kind of racist like
you you literally are saying something
where it's like black people have no
capacity to to comprehend the Kanye West
would be a terrible [ __ ] president if
that was the case then like you know uh
[ __ ] Tim Ryan or Tim Scott uh the the
South Carolina dude like he would be
he'd be the Republican president like
that would that's not a that's not a
thing at all you know
I just realized this so Kanye went on
Tim's pool
Tim's pools Tim Poole's show
he started saying all kind of crazy
anti-semitic [ __ ] Tim gave him the
lightest pushback imaginable and he
stormed out then he goes to Twitter and
says I think yay could win the
presidency
like his reaction absolutely to being
faced with like violent anti-Semitism is
to say this guy this guy is going to win
for the presidency yeah what a [ __ ]
cup I mean he was mad he was mad that
like Kanye West [ __ ] couldn't even
handle a little bit of light pushback
audience I don't know if you watched
that live stream but Tim's audience was
saying El tempor you [ __ ] it up it was
probably groivers mostly like there's no
shot that it was like you know most
normal people most normal people would
have [ __ ] looked at that and been
like I think most people looked at that
and went oh no that's like that's insane
it seems like 90 of the chat
anyway let's do more Nick Fuentes I
think this is important like this guy's
coming up so let's just take a look here
is my boy Nick on Russia and creating
invading Ukraine and now they're going
on about Russia and Vladimir Putin is
Hitler and they say that's not a good
thing and they say
he can't even hide it dude that's what
I'm saying he's such a nerd he's just
nah no shot
[Applause]
we are honored we are humbled and
excited to Welcome to the stage right
now for our first speech and we love to
get to know her much better I think this
is going to be
the beginning of something great the
representative from Georgia Marjorie
Taylor Greene
yes we love them oh thank you so honored
Marjorie Taylor green
associating with only the best
he loved that uh Nick is arguing that
the fact he's a virgin makes him the
least gay person
oh yeah I think he was just like I think
he was memeing here like not to I don't
give a [ __ ] about being charitable to
him but like I think he was joking here
because like I have said verbatim the
same [ __ ] as a joke about like oh Phil
is like yeah but you're not virgin he is
that's true that is that is true porn
stars bro and you have one of those
what do you call those massive vibrators
that like you could Hitachi yeah do you
[ __ ] porn stars and use a hitachis bro
you and him are not the same
thank you
unfortunately he's never gonna you know
repopulate the gene pool no
if only this man had took a Hitachi to
some prime Puss In the words of who said
prime plus
ke keemstar oh keemstar oh God if only
he had got some prime plus like him
maybe he wouldn't be so radical I think
I think right if anything it makes me
not gay totally well because think about
it this way
you know a gay person gay people do date
girls all the time yes really
and when I said on Elijah shape for show
and they said have you ever been in a
romantic relationship have you ever had
sex with a girl and I said no
if you name searched me on Twitter as I
always do all these gay people are
coming out and saying I've had more
girlfriends than Nick I've I've had sex
with more girls than Nick
so like I said last week not only is not
only is that thinking flawed
but actually it's the reverse that
actually makes me really more
heterosexual than anybody yes if if
we're being if we're really being honest
never having a girlfriend never having
sex with a woman
really makes you more heterosexual
because honestly
dating women is gay
having sex with women is gay true honey
he's right having sex with men is gay
and then it's all gay what do we do it's
all gay I'm trapped in a world of gay
yeah that's why he is the least gay uh
man because he has no sex whatsoever how
can I have sex and not be gay it's today
I feel uh
yo you gotta [ __ ] tie that with the
Andrew Cuomo one I am gay wait what we
never you've never seen that we gotta
pull that one oh my God Andrew Cuomo did
that exact same speech of the FIFA guy
did uh where he was like I am Muslim I
I'm gay
I'm disabled I'm New York we uh watched
on the show Once but it's been a while
anyway
I don't know disabled yeah disabled the
day today like a disabled gay immigrant
worker
today I feel like a uh Arab and Arab
yeah
gay I I learned something about that
that like uh actually Italian uh Swiss
people are discriminated against in
Switzerland where they are like they're
told that they're not actually Swiss and
they're instead Italian
did you know that damn I feel bad for
him yeah so sad he only mentioned the
red hair but yeah he didn't even mention
that in class because I was like calling
him Italian and people in the chat were
getting upset at me
um it's because I had uh red hair
all right the morning the truth the only
really straight heterosexual position is
to be an asexual incel
that's it so that's all there is he's
speaking to his audience mgtow a sexual
incel is really the straightest position
that you can have I mean he's just
channeling this to his audience that he
knows uh is like uh turbo virgins you
know yeah he's playing straight to them
um let's see
Nick uses the n-word describing Steve
Bannon as a fat uh restart
I love how he hates all other
conservatives I think that's awesome we
we censored this right the heavy n-word
usage
yes let's see we are the only ones that
aren't racist we're the only ones
ironically and I and I know this is
going to come across in a certain way
but the irony is people accuse us of
hating black people and we're the only
ones to treat black people with like
actual respect honestly respect enough
to tell them hey stop committing crimes
stop stop being so illiterate in schools
yeah he's so nice that's so awesome you
told them that I mean why don't they
listen yeah listen up black people yeah
no he's he's he's so nice and not racist
it's obvious he respects me he's like
yeah he it's respect it's out of respect
that he's being like a white supremacist
actually makes sense it's cool with them
you know they're just human beings to us
they're just real human beings yeah we
stand for real human beings truly but we
also stand for whites
right anyway anyway so that's sort of an
aside but it is a little bit funny this
comes from Bannon he's like oh she's
getting a little bit too sympathetic to
the blacks and but we're footstep for
white people yeah okay Dodge the bullet
there this this is getter getter is run
by Bannon and Bannon is the fat [ __ ]
that goes on these shows and says we're
gonna have African Americans voting 50
for republicans and we're going to flood
the Zone
oh my God literally dude Kanye West is
hanging out with the dude who called it
the n-word vote yeah I mean he but he is
anti-black Kanye West literally said he
wants to be he's a billionaire in his
like most manic stage he was like I'm a
billionaire which means like I'm gonna
be a white person like I'm gonna be a
white white guy you know so it's no
accident it's no mistake that he's like
he is openly anti-black like that
started way before he hung out with Nick
Fuentes like he's been anti-black for a
minute it's kind of it's really
interesting because no one really people
don't really address that like I have
covered this extensively and talked
about how anti-blackay was is
extensively but for for some reason like
that's not a message because like
anti-blackness is so deeply uh embedded
in the American identity like being
anti-black and being uh and you know
abiding by white supremacist values
without even recognizing it is so deeply
an American value that like people
didn't even [ __ ] consider that at all
for the most part what platform is Nick
on dude don't even I don't don't even
say it it's just is it like it's no even
lower than Rumble yes yes yes there is
like even more yeah there's just like
fun like where can you say this [ __ ]
yeah no there's there's like literally
just botted [ __ ] uh websites oh no
dude Alex Jones just tweeted from yay's
account and everyone's got to ban him
Elon has to ban him he banned ELO I love
the First Amendment long live yay I pray
to Jesus that Elon is for real that's
all that's that's what Alex tweeted okay
bro you could do better than that lame-o
yeah those on these shelves and says
that
that one slipped out oh [ __ ] he's like
whoops didn't mean to say the n-word
there but ah you guys understood wait
Alex Jones is banned on Twitter him
tweeting on Kanye West account means
just like you tweeted on uh ela's
account he needs to be banned
immediately what the [ __ ] he look when I
tweeted that joke from Ila's account
yeah she got banned in 20 [ __ ]
minutes that's crazy so and that was
when Twitter headquarters was empty
uh so let's see if he has the balls to
banye I don't think he'll do it I don't
think he'll do it actually
and Alex Jones literally was like uh
or not Elon Musk was like I have no
sympathy for Alex Jones who [ __ ] got
those kids killed so I think they're
doing it to Beta band I think to see if
like
to see if it'll actually get banned he
should but he Elon won't he's a giant
[ __ ] [ __ ]
vagina what's better than [ __ ] I don't
like that term can you call my mangina
primer I don't know I mean I I use it
for example it is misogynistic it is and
so I try to phase it out but there's
it's hard to find a replacement I like
mangina because it's kind of like in
between the genders
[Music]
say like I was transphobic or something
um I don't know I I don't know
I don't know I'm not I'm not a part of
the the Elder Council okay I mean the
trans Elder the trans Elder Council that
gets together and discusses these things
Ethan didn't you yeah Ela was the one
that tweeted it uh Fuentes is tweeting
from his account now too what do we got
it's in the Discord
should we report it I mean we should
report it right yeah this this is Christ
this is King America First grouper
check it out oh that's so funny dude I'm
sorry you're such a [ __ ] loser dude
groeper
I said it I'm so bad like that's who
that's who kind of is like associating
himself with that's [ __ ] awesome all
right so the ball's in Elon the
bible.com yeah bible.com what is
bible.com I [ __ ] I don't know it's
just get a free Bible for your phone
there it is it's gonna stop you yeah the
the Infowars uh.com and the Cozy TV is
like the the damaging ones were like
they're they are they are exhausting
they are literally [ __ ] they are
using kind of like a [ __ ] Fleshlight
okay yeah straight up yeah I'm sorry
this is the most exploitation I've ever
seen it is so [ __ ] humiliating that
they're using one of the most famous
black men on the planet to promote a
white supremacist website it is so
[ __ ] embarrassing it is so awful like
I don't know what to say about it beyond
that that is what's going on right now
this is like
it's like ritualistic humiliation dude
I'm getting lots of Vetoes on the
mangina
someone asked what's a grouper just
means like Nazi right I mean I don't
know what griper means Grover is just
like these [ __ ] losers called
themselves he's like Pepe Pepe was like
reclaimed uh by the creator of Pepe uh
and and so like they moved on and they
were like no actually we're groupers
where's like ooh we're still silly like
4chan [ __ ] post yeah it doesn't even
[ __ ] matter yeah it's just irrelevant
yes so um but you keep saying yeah you
know it's been obviously we know yay has
is bipolar
but I've seen him in a manic State and
I'm familiar with like what manic States
look like
I he doesn't strike me as someone in a
manic State he seems intentional with
what he's doing right now
yeah it seems I don't know I mean this
is like career suicide like I don't know
when you're manic you're almost you
become delusional and in some cases
borderline uh straight up psychosis yeah
I think I think he has paranoid
delusions for sure I mean he literally
said you talk ill about baby nanya
they'll come and execute you like that's
but like paranoid it seems
he seems based on what I've seen of him
and other people in manic States
relatively
grounded yeah I don't think he's manic
right now which is kind of even crazier
uh thank you for the handy sniffer they
says they want our podcast to be longer
that's that's Hassan he has another job
man
yeah to go twitch stream all right I'm
sorry yeah
you know am I Jewish I'm not
anyway here's more Nick Fuente he tells
the Jews to stop being so disrespectful
when are white people gonna stand up yes
and say that how dare you and white
people are always apologetic oh no no
I'm not a Nazi oh no I'm not antis I
would never no no I'm not this I'm not
deaf hang on first of all how dare you
how dare you this is a decent Nation
this is a good nation of good people and
of anything this nation welcomed
Jewish people into America and then this
is literally not true right yeah didn't
we didn't America turn away [ __ ] Jews
that's not executed yeah but I like how
he's taking credit for that me the
Americans we've welcomed in the Jews yes
there were 30 000 Nazis in Madison
Square Garden at the peak of the [ __ ]
you know American Nazi movement which
this [ __ ] loser wishes he was a part
of man God there if only that's the best
part about all this is like ultimately
you are such a [ __ ] major L holder
you know what I mean you're literally
riding for a bunch of [ __ ] losers
like not only is there world view just
awful and and transparently silly and
and pathetic and at its worst obviously
deeply violent but they lost you lost
and your movement has no momentum it
peaked once again at unite the right in
Charlottesville which Nick was a part of
by the way and then it [ __ ] withered
away again and now they're so
desperately trying to clean on to any
kind of relevancy they can and the the
main thing about these guys is like
ultimately they can't stop themselves
they have to come out and be like I'm
different than the other conservatives
and and openly State their desires and
when that happens it's like most people
are still going to be like nah that's
too much you're a [ __ ] gross weird
nerd you know what I mean Richard
Spencer had the undercut he he dressed
adequately and then went on CNN and they
would like interview him regularly which
was psychotic in my opinion shouldn't
have done that CNN should have never
done that yeah they shouldn't do this
for Nick Fuentes either
way more radical than but Richard no no
they're not they're of the same variety
you think so yes one I guess he just
says bro they're both Nazis like what do
you mean how much more radical can you
be than [ __ ] yes you know just a
straight out and about Nazi
well by the way uh someone in chat Berry
Butterfly Kisses said God my boyfriend
loves Nick Fuentes I hate it so much I
don't know what to tell you but I don't
think that and I and I'm not quick to
say this but that is not a relationship
you want to be in you are dating a
[ __ ] Nazi wait what he's
dating someone who loves Nick Fuentes
yeah and she watches this show ew like
how do you live you can't live those two
lives
not even oh God like that's not cute
like oh my boyfriend just is into like
sports all the time uh like no yeah get
a [ __ ] better hobby dude watch One
Piece what the [ __ ] wrong with you one
piece forever I I just
I got the dogs barking all right so
let's continue with anything America
welcomed
yes throughout the 20th
successful in media and Hollywood how
dare they brow beat us and call us Nazis
and call us
exterminationists and say we're
murderers first of all I've never heard
anyone say that I think you're the only
one that gets told that yeah
I'm pretty sure but why are you even
denying it that's literally who you are
what do you want because we profess the
same faith that we always have because
because of our ancestors who built this
country that so graciously welcomed you
here how disrespectful how dare you
ingrate how dare you
that's my feeling about it I've heard
enough about this Holocaust I've heard
enough about it no I don't want to hear
one more time about it no enough about
that yeah how about we hear about the
generosity of America that brought you
here yes we hear Holocaust museums how
about some gratitude museums how about
some gratitude
yeah for Christendom how about some
gratitude for European civilization I
love when you like ride America it's
like funny and all we get is this it's
funny when he rides for like
Christianity like how about some
gratitude like [ __ ] you didn't do any
of that like shut the [ __ ] up like you
literally live in your parents basement
Michael said thank you what the [ __ ] is
that like what do you mean it's just
like concept is like fundamentally
flawed but I do love the like mythology
that people love to engage in because
like we are a broken nation and I think
that a lot of people see like uh you
know hyper consumption and and that
being the only cultural signifier that
they can like associate with or create a
sense of community around whether it's
your favorite sports team or even your
favorite political commentators right
and you you band around that so like
these people are looking for something
more meaningful than that so what do
they search for they search for like
this deep desire they search for this
like mythology that they've crafted for
themselves and if you're like a gigantic
goober like Nick Fuentes uh who is
Hispanic by the way which is ironic
because he's a hispanic white
supremacist
um
is is this like this notion that like uh
there is this Christian Excellence uh
and and you know then you end up saying
insane [ __ ] like the original sin you
know what I mean Jews uh were
responsible for Jesus Christ being
[ __ ] uh you know
put on a cross or whatever the [ __ ]
right it's like dude what are you like
you're not Roman like what's happening
right now why do you care about this
it's not a real thing to be upset about
Hitler
yeah well there's also that to consider
Ting all we get is this blood libel
insults how dare you you want to talk
about a holocaust you know the real
Holocaust was Jesus Christ being
crucified oh no you want to talk about a
holocaust yeah I was there yeah it's
just like it's an insane thing to be
like even fake upset about you know
but the whole thing of being mad that
like quote unquote the Jews killed Jesus
which obviously is like anti-semitic
propaganda of course it was the Romans
who killed him but regardless of that
I mean it's debated if he even existed
in the way that they know so it's like
whatever we're debating is silly but
um
isn't that the whole reason why
Christianity exists because he died like
it was all part of his plan why are you
mad at Jews for Killing Jesus he's God
the [ __ ] is infallible God like
this is all why you mad at me bro this
is what he wanted that's the blood you
know it's a [ __ ] that I do
I was just doing my part so you could
sit in your parents basement and cry
about it [ __ ] yeah and I do it
again give me the spear [ __ ]
I'll do it again you're gonna piss off
the [ __ ] weird hysterical nerds dude
good if Jesus was here on a cross like
that spirit
no he's not gonna be funny if he got
banned that's an insane thing no no shot
give me the hammer and the spikes I'm
putting his ass up there if someone
could do it it's Ethan he'll find a way
I'll do it again
okay I liked it the first time and I'll
do it again Nick
I'm getting on a call with all my Jewish
brothers and sisters there's 30 minutes
left I really want to make Dan proud
let's let's I'm you know what I'm
planning this Christmas no I'm not
executing of Jesus Christ no dedicated
to Nick Fuentes your choice caramel
apples are great
it's not thick come on this isn't that
bad
it's not I'm not even worried about that
come on let's get some and I'll do it he
said that he's at the real Holocaust is
Jesus Christ being crucified this is so
[ __ ] stupid it doesn't even make
sense it's what he wanted he literally
wanted that yeah
um
um so what else what else do we got on
the on the Nick Fuentes [ __ ] yeah yeah
yeah let's move on
thank you Zach for that Nagila Hava
Nagila yeah
okay love that let's see what we get
here
oh a new oh no got erased
the link didn't work
now what oh [ __ ] I don't know
all right as you look for that I'll keep
moving on on the neck fuentas
um
Nick Fuentes says Americans oh this
one's good this is a good one you guys
are gonna like this one
you're Jill
you're either a Catholic you're with the
Jews that's how it is that's the way the
world is
so anyway that's that I wonder what he
thinks about the wait so he's wait
that's kind of wild though because like
there's other stuff well it's weird
because like America is not a Catholic
nation and has never been a Catholic
Nation America is a nation that was
built by white Anglo-Saxon Protestants
right and as a matter of fact it was
kind of a big deal way back in the day
when like JFK was like the first
Catholic President right
um and uh wasps and Catholics if you go
far enough back in time uh or at least
like you know Protestant Catholics have
been duking it out for quite some time
you know uh so it is interesting where
he's saying like uh America must be an
authoritarian Catholic Nation
because I don't think the Wasps who have
been in control would be uh in in favor
of that not at all but I like that he's
Catholic because uh obviously they have
a long tradition of
uh I mean Joe Brandon is Catholic yeah
BBC I'm Irish
that's a big game man it's a big game
what was the context of that
no he said that's a big game oh [ __ ] you
think he actually said that's a bit gay
man that's what I heard and I thought
he's like he's like 45 years old
obviously that that's what I heard do
it's a bit gay man that's a big game man
that's what I heard too why are people
spamming share what you want to hear
what
people are spamming uh shrimps and chat
I don't understand the context there
oh no I missed that oh so you're either
a Catholic or your Jew yeah you're
either a Catholic you're with the Jews
that's how it is that's the way the
world is
so anyway that's that and when our
Catholics going to start asserting their
control yes I want Catholics to run this
country not Jews
there's never been a Jewish president
for the record
yeah that's what you think
they said Obama was Muslims but he was
actually Jewish that's right I see too
and [ __ ] too did you consider that
what's shrimp chat you guys what the
[ __ ] going on I'm trying to find an
origin I'm not fighting not Jews and I
don't think that's controversial
I want this country to have Catholic
media Catholic Hollywood Catholic
government I want this to be a Catholic
occupied government not a Jewish
occupied government that's not
controversial for us it may be
controversial for you it's not
controversial for us we are Christians
you're not it's not they could say it's
eyebrow raising for who these people
with the [ __ ] cubes on their head
with the [ __ ] linen line wrapped
around the city
he may be who cares about them in their
eyebrows and their freaking descriptions
of movies it's not controversial for us
we're Christians
you know what's eyebrow raising for us
wearing a cube on your head
is I make that when I see when I see
some guy with a freaking thing wrapped
around his house big hat I'm like what
what he's talking about to fill in I
think what the [ __ ] it's like Ultra
Orthodox day bro that's what this that's
what's wild about these [ __ ]
like you know Matt Walsh knows
everything about trans people okay
literally he's like investigating deep
translore same with Nick Fuentes he's
obsessed with like Jewish people he
knows [ __ ] about Jewish people that I
don't [ __ ] know like that's crazy
dude yeah and by the way he's talking
about how silly Orthodox Jews look but
like I don't know if y'all seen this but
this dude is I mean like these
[ __ ] dressed these guys are
closer to like drag queen than they are
dude yeah he dressed like a [ __ ] Dark
Souls boss which I think is cool by the
way I have no issues with that I think
it's fire but how are you gonna hate how
are you gonna think drag shows are
grooming and then this [ __ ] and
this is your guy this guy is basically
the star of root RuPaul's Drag Race or
whatever yeah the dub on that any day of
the week
no for sure I think like you know dude
I will stand by this nothing touches uh
black Israelite drip though right I mean
that is your straight Mortal Kombat dude
like that's just straight up like a
curtain yeah
it's fire I think that I mean have you
seen like the pope guard they they were
some [ __ ] wonky ass yeah yeah they
were they were some crazy ass [ __ ] too
but like but that's like fun they're
doing dress-up you know that's what I'm
saying though that's fun that's you'd be
like oh the or the Orthodox Jews with
the cubes on their head like imagine
like what are you defending against dog
like well I'm not gonna attack the pub
with a trebuchet you know what I mean
get him the Jews aren't gonna get like
[ __ ] are using AR-15s you have
a like a like a spear
I mean that's fire that's fire getting
Medieval Times yeah the drip is unreal
dude
we got some Wild clips um okay good good
good good good
nice we got some updates from uh
I see two is that yeah okay okay from
the Kanye Alex Jones which is live right
now say like you like the you like the
uniforms but that's about it oh we we no
I there's a lot of things that I love
about Hitler
he's trying to do something he's really
trying to do something
I I I I just I don't know I don't know
anymore I think like maybe he's maybe
he's like [ __ ]
um
I I think like
he's so hopped up on like being Manic
and so narcissistic that he thinks he
can get away with this maybe like and he
has this like deep delusion that he
thinks he is like fighting for this
righteous cause
to defend you know the defenseless uh
Nazis and Adolf Hitler
it's [ __ ] nuts okay like you like the
you like the uniforms but that's about
it oh we we no I don't keep trying to
save them a lot of things I love about
Hitler and you see Nick he's like so on
board with that and there's just
something weird going on here
there's so much I love well let's watch
the second one
let's see here
oh they just keep coming through eh Ian
here's the second one
I'm tired of hearing I'm a Nazi I'm
really sick because I'm not
but I think by them falsely accusing
people some people are going to become
nice I am I am
now what I am now what now I'm a Nazi
Arya Manuel isn't that why is he
attacking Arya Manuel
wait who is that he's the head of uh WM
yeah he's a he's Rahm emanuel's brother
he's Ari Gold and Entourage yeah based
after him he's the head of what WWE
William Morris yeah oh is he Jewish yeah
yeah he's like there you go one of the
top Jews I guess there you go top G cop
J adopt you there you go you answered
your own question I mean like like Ari
Emmanuel not necessarily known as a good
dude okay not not a great guy uh but
like I don't know why the [ __ ] he's
singling him out I guess is because it's
Hollywood
like you're supposed to be from Chicago
get mad at ROM what the [ __ ] be like Ari
your brother sucks you know what I mean
it's crazy that I just can't I don't
understand this character because Kanye
went from George Bush hates black people
too I hate black people yeah interesting
um it's it's like that he's just
I think um
I mean there's a there's a larger reason
for this that that like a lot of this is
something I've uh been fascinated by and
have studied uh and talked to my friends
about quite frequently about like uh
black Israelite and other kinds of like
hotep theories it stems from a place of
of uh American Education being centered
around white supremacist values that
whitewash uh the uh obscene inhumane
cruel practices that came with slavery
so I think uh that and the
intergenerational trauma that has gone
unaddressed creates this like uh
educational power vacuum where some
people want to look for alternative
history that also kind of like hides the
shame
um and
and and tries to
tries to re-educate people in a
different direction uh in that endless
Endeavor uh you could potentially arrive
at what conservatives call CRT okay
which is just basically uh anything that
centers black people African people as
human beings Critical with autonomy and
and uh you know that is of course cast
aside as like dangerous education in
this country but if you can arrive at
that or you can arrive at this kind of
[ __ ] and then ultimately uh decide that
you yourself have conservative values
Kanye West is a billionaire he has some
reactionary Tendencies that's not that
uh strange to assume and then the more
conservative you become
the more your conservatism uh revolves
around how different you are than every
other uh uh black person because
in a weird way you are also saying that
like black people are a monolith as a
voting Bloc they're all Democrat and
that you're not that so you're still
anchoring your entire world view in a
very reactionary way around what other
people assume black people are like and
those other people that assume black
people are like that are still racist
you know what I mean because it's very
hard to to quote unquote remove yourself
from the Matrix in that regard when the
Matrix is white supremacist
by the way update on Tim Poole's sister
she's going to call in next week oh hell
yeah look forward to that that'll be
great here and I'm a Nazi I'm really
sick I'm not
dude yay's making Alex Jones look sane
which is crazy I think by them falsely
accusing people some people are going to
become not he's a good propaganda he
knows not what I am not what now I'm a
Nazi Arya Manuel isn't that now what
it's so crazy uh Ian send a full version
of that it's actually is that the third
one yeah so okay let's get the longer
version
no I get you're explaining that like you
said you love the zionists you don't
agree with someone things are doing even
though you don't support a lot of what's
Happening seriously so I've really
studied a lot of history plus I had
family that was there and so I mean I I
don't think Hitler was a good guy I get
the uh the Hugo Boss uniforms amazing uh
but I mean just because you're in love
with the design you're a designer can we
just kind of say like you like the you
like the uniforms but that's about it
bro he's trying so hard he said he's a
Nazi like 20 times Alex while he's still
trying to save him I love the the
unicorns I love the cars too right
Hitler did have swag but besides that I
mean yeah listen you and I both Drive
German so you know I'll see myself out
of that conversation they did had swag I
mean that's part of the what I mean who
denies no they care yeah fascists uh
ironic because like they were uh they
considered art to be morally degenerate
but did care about Aesthetics a lot to a
certain degree that like because
Fashions know like they have to promote
their [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah and they
recognize that uh the Aesthetics were a
big part of that promotion which is why
you know the Hugo Boss thing and the
cars and everything else that you've
seen no they were they were dripping the
[ __ ] out and and like fashion and in you
know uh the blood of uh recently slain
Jews but you know drip is drip
yeah the drip was yeah there's a lot of
things that I love about Hitler look at
that look at Nick look at that things
hey what did you think about that
they're The Leftovers of World War II
they support zielinski and attacking
Russia so you like the Azog of Italian I
love everything I don't know what the
[ __ ] you're talking about he doesn't
know what that is I literally just
learned who's net in Yahoo two weeks ago
like he Alex Jones should have like
distance himself or Kanye by being like
you like the Aesop Battalion I don't
like those guys because they're
anti-russia I'm pro-russia they're
anti-russia you like those guys it's
like bro he doesn't know he just found
out who Netanyahu is last week brother
what are you doing here's Nick off this
engaging in some good old-fashioned
Holocaust denial says if I take one hour
to cook a batch of food oh yeah the
cookie
working 24 hours a day every day for
five years how long does it take Cookie
Monster to make six million batches of
cookies
I don't know that's a good question
certainly uh oh no no it doesn't really
sound correct to me wait a second it
takes one hour to cook a batch of
cookies and you have 15 ovens probably
in four different kitchens right doing
24 hours a day every day for five years
how long would it take you to make six
million hmm I don't know it certainly
wouldn't be five years right the math
doesn't seem to add up there
the math doesn't quite seem to add up
there I don't think you'd result uh in 6
million maybe 200 to 300 000 cookies
probably 200 to 300 000 cookies baked I
think his own math comes to like 7.8
million
it does it really yeah I think like the
map that he put forward is is also like
checks out yeah not only does it check
out but it's more than that yeah love
that that if you took aerial photographs
over the kitchens you would need to see
certain Smoke Stacks to release there
were Smoke Stacks I don't know why bro
entirely recovered in Ash in the ash of
of and and
humans like it's like it's well
documented bro it is one of the more
well-documented atrocities not these
were like kind of into you know fashion
and documentation yeah and documenting
their horrific atrocities as though it
was like super nice that they were doing
that a big Flex
yeah baking the cookies and the Smoke
Stacks would project certain Shadows but
I guess they're not visible in the
aerial photographs taking over the
kitchens moreover
aerial photographs we were talking about
1940s
are we talking about wow doing classic
like the showers were actually for
showers and there were swimming pools so
like how could you claim that it was
like they're swimming pools yeah nice
he's saying like it's it's just old
school uh uh Holocaust denialism based
on nothing by the way yeah it's just
completely transparently made up the
Nazi journals are like no we use these
to exterminate people well that's why
they open those showers that's why they
always say like the Holocaust didn't
happen but it'd be really cool if it did
yeah that's like what their follow-up is
usually
the Holocaust didn't happen but we're
trying to make it real here folks yeah
it's really nice cheap enough for Mass
cookie storage underground
um and so there's a lot of things you
know in the cookie kitchen they say that
the ovens are uh wooden and they have
Windows on them and they're not Totally
Secure and the ovens that they use they
they actually did sort of an ad hoc use
of that particular kind of oven even
though they made a perfectly good design
with purpose for delousing I mean you
know for something else
so none of it really adds up I don't
know it just kind of doesn't really make
sense this this crazy cooking yeah Nick
has it all figured out there this kitten
is parents basement uh has checkmated
historians and literal
documents from the Nazis
uh finally I know you're running out of
time here we've had so much fun uh
but here's the last Nick Fuentes clip
for you guys he says for them too the
Jim Crow segregation who cares no number
one but number two who cares who cares
you know enough with the Jim Crow stuff
who cares right oh yeah to drink out of
a different water fountain big [ __ ]
deal positive I need to go to a
different schools
you're talking about segregation as
though it's not a big [ __ ] deal right
meanwhile his entire argument about like
white people being oppressed hinges on
like other people having sex like he's
like white people are under attack and
being replaced because people are
getting into like committed loving
relationships in interracial couples
which is like eliminating the white gene
pool and that is the worst form of
Oppression and bullying that could ever
happen simultaneously systemic
discrimination that's codified and
institutionalizes like ah big [ __ ]
deal
yeah just it's it's a blaring hypocrisy
we care when it's white people we don't
care when it's black people it's just
ridiculous
well they're water found in that famous
picture
worse who cares grow up drink out of the
[ __ ] water fountain it's it's water
it's the same
you know and uh you know even if it was
bad who cares even if it hadn't let in
it who cares who cares is better it's
better in general we all agree it was
better for them it's better for us
better in general we all agree better
for them it was better for them we all
agree yeah so this guy Trump met him
with Kanye and said uh this guy really
gets me well Trump loves Tucker Carlson
and Tucker Carlson has ideas almost
identical to Nick Fuentes the only
difference is Tucker Carlson will never
say yeah Jewish things like he will
never say things about Jews right no
that's the main difference between
Tucker Carlson and and uh Nick Fuentes
that Tucker knows what he's allowed to
say and what boundaries he's not allowed
to push
that's it that's the main difference
there yeah he's way smarter about it
Ben now is reaping what he sowed which
was exactly my the joke I made that I
got banned for he says a good way not to
accidentally dine with a vile racist
talking about Nick Fuentes
and anti-semite and Kanye I guess you
don't know is to not to dine with a vile
racist and anti-semite you do know
let me read that again because I think I
butchered it a good way not to
accidentally dine with the vile race is
anti-semite you don't know it's not to
dine with the wild race sentence you do
know so he's talking about Trump hosting
yay who brought Nick Fuentes and this
these are his people Ben how do you know
what you're talking about these are your
folks man yeah
I made this joke before but it's like
the onion article where it's like why
are all these homosexuals sucking my
dick all the time like why are all these
people that have aligned myself with
constantly saying anti-semitic things I
don't understand yeah and so why are all
these anti-semites that I've aligned
myself with are being anti-semitic
they're on my payroll what the [ __ ]
they're supposed to be more obedient to
me yeah uh uh Shapiro is now beefing
with yay on Twitter Shapiro starvingly
accepts a hundred thousand from one of
my opponents then tries to trash me they
say and I say get him I say get him yay
you're right let him fight dude it's
totally I love it love it
um
Ben says Sally you've trashed yourself
you didn't need my help it wasn't me it
wasn't the Jews it was you well
debatable there Ben
I think that
um a lot of Americans as a final note
I'll say this much I think that a lot of
Americans hold on to
um white supremacist values without
recognizing that said values are white
supremacists right
but uh moments like this where those
values are associated with overt white
supremacy or overt Nazism are moments
where they go no no I don't want that
that's that's crazy that guy's [ __ ]
weird especially if
especially if the Vibes and I can't
believe I'm saying this is a serious
subject matter but like Vibes are very
important in this regard if it's like
you know this Relentless weird sniveling
[ __ ] nerd like Nick Fuentes like most
people are going to look at that and go
like no no dude you're no you're you're
like a nerd for racism like I don't want
to be associated with that you know what
I mean like the 1350 narrative like the
idea that like black people are
criminals and violent like a lot of
Americans feel that way okay they feel
that way and it is a racist way to feel
uh especially if you are not recognizing
the external factors considering the
external conditions that have created
the never-ending cycle of socioeconomic
uh conditions in poverty right cycle of
poverty which begets violence
um that is racist inherently is
inherently racist statement you learn
that through social conditioning so
that's why I say like there's a baseline
of racism that a lot of people in
America are socially conditioned into
believing but the moment that you
[ __ ] flip the switch and say no no
I'm like textbook races I'm like a
textbook Nazi most people look at that
and go nope nope that's not for me now
[ __ ] that will it be an uh will it be a
moment for self-reflection I don't think
so these are you know these are these
are institutionalized attitudes it's
gonna be very difficult to overcome that
and you have to personally seek uh
within uh that change it's not going to
happen with external forces usually
however like I said I think that this
level of overt white supremacy is a
toxic brand so toxic that even Trump
distance themselves yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah but they're making Headway that's
again but going off what you said so I
showed uh Ben is now jousting with Kanye
and calling him an anti-semite and Nick
Fuentes is anti-semite
but just [ __ ] last month and this is
what I'm saying Ben Shapiro reaping what
he sows he's propping up people who are
anti-semitic or like anti-semitic
adjacent look what he said about I
really don't care about people look what
the [ __ ] he said about him last month
I really don't care I see people's
responses I perform for audience of one
and that's God
wow I mean frankly it sounds fantastic
much more sane than virtually everybody
else in public life right and again we
are a society that rewards people for
twerking in thongs while being 150
pounds away but if you have an artist
who creates art in which people sing
about an artist he did that a recent
show and where you wear a badge honoring
The Unborn and where you say that you do
your work on behalf of the almighty
rather than on behalf of the muelling
gaggles of of foolish press members who
seem to be impressed mainly by
transgressivism yes that's that's the
real crazy according to he loves Kanye
he's a genius he's an artist he's a
Trailblazer we love him right yeah
uh by the way this is after uh yay had
said he's going def Con 3 on Jewish
people and if we just go back a little
tiny bit here
um yeah he was trying to say like oh
some of the stuff that he's saying is
like maybe anti-semitic but maybe
misunderstood or whatever but like he's
saying enough about the conservative
movement that I agree with him so you
know he likes genius I like I I tweet
about this uh before it was like it's
the same [ __ ] they loved it when Mama
was repeating clandest Owens is talking
points verbatim because those were
anti-black talking points but the moment
he switched it over and like said some
other stuff that Gladys Owens has said
at least in a way that is like overt uh
and anti-semitic then all of a sudden
it's a big No-No it's like oh you're
giving the game away stop wait wait
what's been true this guy he's the most
Jewish [ __ ] in the country a
good way not to accidentally dine with
vile racist and anti wait so Kanye is
now a vile racist and anti-semite what
happened bro a month ago you're talking
about he's a genius anyway he's a piece
of [ __ ] fake friends and phony yeah and
like I said you know if I'm not going to
say what I said last time because
apparently that's offensive and
anti-Semitic unlike Ben Shapiro who was
courting promoting platforming people
that um and and and uh complimenting
people that
uh want to basically kill Jews he just
tweeted this oh yeah yay is clearly
suffering from a mental breakdown it's
an act of Cruelty to have him on the air
at this point he needs treatment on
Spotlight I agree that people need to
stop airing him but at the same time
I can't help but think that he's still
running D for him
now what you know he want he wants the
aid to go back to the roots and [ __ ]
uh go back to just being like I'm
Christian and uh you know I'm
anti-abortion and all this stuff which
of course
comes with the package of anti-Semitism
as well depending on like what flavor of
conservatism you have arrived at
yeah well so there it is the country is
[ __ ] wild right now the whole
conservative movement is really really
really going wild and let's do it [ __ ]
it let's get Kanye and Nick Fuentes in
there for p and VP and let's just see
what happens what do we say but actually
interestingly I I do think that Trump
hosting Nick Fuentes and yay actually
hurt him a lot I think people are
are not uh down with that although we'll
see you know
so there it is
I guess you got to go right yeah yeah
yeah yeah so we're gonna wrap it up here
thank you Hassan nice to see you
this was wonderful yeah it was a good
time next week we're gonna have uh you
know some some very interesting things
happen
what
potentially
is that what you're talking about Lisa
yes yeah we're gonna make it happen oh
it's scheduler yeah oh mama yeah I was
reading I was reading the Discord I was
reading it I love it I love so that's
gonna be fun yes yes yes tell us
everything yeah is this a new clip
yeah oh [ __ ] wait hold on before you
send it on one final now and uh so
you're in love with the with the with
the with the arc the the look of it and
he didn't kill six million Jews that's
just like factually incorrectly show me
your stuff
that's it I said this like I think I
said like three months ago I was like
Kanye West hasn't like read the lore yet
like deep enough to get to the [ __ ]
six million Jews were not murdered in
the Holocaust point and he's he's
arrived
so wait what how did Alex react to that
let me see like factually incorrect yeah
let's get the Ronald Reagan clip they
showed me yesterday oh he oh he he moves
on he's like I didn't hear that yeah
pull him up Ronald Reagan also famously
said African diplomats are monkeys by
the way you know not a not exactly a
beacon of uh you know uh pro-blackness
there
not to throw you I'm not trying to do
anything with this uh Ian I'm genuinely
not trying to do a meme I know you you
used to be a fan of Kanye back back back
before all this [ __ ] started it must be
so weird for you to see him like this
you're so [ __ ] crazy like is it it's
not even the same person what is
happening here I mean what do you I just
what are your thoughts Ian
uh
uh I I feel like uh as a old-time Kanye
fan
there was always like a couple different
directions that uh oh I don't have a
camera that he could go in one is like
channeling all this creative energy into
all sorts of you know artistic things
and then just going completely off the
rails and so
I'm not exactly shocked in a weird way
interesting it's just
he he went down the the dark timeline I
guess damn but that's interesting I
think the wrong people he got in with
the wrong people man I don't know what
to say
yeah but it's it's so far gone now he is
completely I don't think there's any
sort of recourse today
so it's done
I wonder what's gonna happen where he's
gonna be in five years from now like can
he survive this in any way like not
really
I think what might start happening is uh
streaming services are going to take his
music down I think especially after
today yeah today was the uh big uh yeah
this is It's Over finale I mean it's
funny because like it shouldn't get to
this point for people to recognize when
someone is like very clearly either
mentally ill or also a Nazi or why not
both in the case of Kanye West but it it
literally had to get to a point where he
had to say for four hours straight on
the [ __ ] you know Sandy Hook denial
uh podcast that he loves Hitler and
against the guy who got sued
successfully for like billions of
[ __ ] dollars for denying Sandy Hook
happening looking like the sane one in
that conversation where even he has the
understanding not to just like openly
[ __ ] state that he loves Adolf Hitler
but Kai was like nah I do I [ __ ] love
that [ __ ] I gotta I kind of want to go
back and watch that whole thing because
it seems like now 200 000 a month in
child support too by the way I gotta say
I don't know how he's going to do that
he's a billionaire I just I like I like
folk is going to do that Kim and Kanye
aside of who they are I mean of of like
whoever Kanye is now but how does Kim
Kardashian who's probably richer than
Kanye at this point get 200 000 in child
support I don't understand that either I
don't know how the [ __ ] that happened
divorce in court Divorce Court slid by
the lit by the Jewish people is that
Jewish divorce court like family court
is the most radicalizing force in this
country I've talked about this I've
joked about this for many many years now
and uh you know I I didn't realize that
kind of was gonna [ __ ] get
disraticalized from that process but uh
you know yeah
there's no full [ __ ] Nazi holy [ __ ]
[ __ ] and they can't drop someone says
she's take well child support is based
off income yeah I know but she's a
gajillionaire she's richer than he is
yeah also if they're divorced like she
must have had a prenup with them because
if they're divorcing and she makes more
theoretically she should be the one
paying his ass
uh alimony or yeah but apparently they
live with child support is I don't think
he's I don't think Kanye West is coming
anywhere near his children for after all
this [ __ ] okay I'll be honest like I
doubt I doubt any judge is gonna be like
no we we should let you uh be around
your children
yeah it's sad
those kids do need a lot of protection
to be honest
it probably costs a lot of [ __ ] money
to have 24-hour like security team
someone says she's not richer than him I
think she's richer than him I think he
might be richer than him now dude and
like the skims thing has been not I
think Kim Kardashian is richer get your
[ __ ] ass up like genuinely
I think she's been richer though too
like Kim Kardashian net worth
1.8 billion she's way [ __ ]
richer than Kanye she passed him in
2022.
that's this year l
ol yeah she's rich as [ __ ] I'm
telling you but whatever who cares
they're both super rich
but yeah they'd live with her okay they
live with her they need the protection
and uh there it is
they both agreed to the terms of the
settlement right they came to uh yeah I
feel sad for the kids man that [ __ ]
sucks so bad
but it is what it is and um
someone says Pete Davidson actually
radicalized Kanye more of the divorce
court I think that is a big component
certainly I agree sure
I gotta tell you I think Pete Davidson's
got to be uh breathing a sigh of relief
with Kanye on this absolute war path now
he doesn't want to get in the in the
line of that but anyway okay we gotta
wrap it up guys thank you so much all
right we'll be see you guys tomorrow
Friday after dark Hassan great to see
you as always we'll see you guys next
week with Temple's sister oh yeah that's
gonna be fun
[Music]
all right